i'm very excited about that first comes
love then comes marriage
then comes nicki minaj's sexy pregnancy
announcement on instagram
wait that's not how the saying goes yep
the 37 year old rapper announced on
instagram monday that she's expecting
her first child with husband kenneth
petty
i'm very excited posting this pic with
the caption
preggers yes absolutely and i'll wear
that title proudly too that's nikki
looking
freaking fire with a bright yellow dew a
blinged out bikini
and platform heels cradling her sweet
little baby bump
i'm a bad [ __ ] this is crazy can't get
enough of the cuteness
well you're in luck yes nikki followed
that post up with two more snaps writing
love
marriage baby carriage overflowing with
excitement and gratitude
thank you all for the well wishes
there's also this pic
snapped by david lachapelle nikki
channeling the virgin mary
and while nikki's loyal barbs flooded
the comment section with those well
wishes
some of her fans weren't all that
surprised by the big reveal
[Music]
back in may after nicki hopped on the
remix of dojicat's hit
say-so fans went nuts claiming at one
point in the song
they could hear nicki whispering that
she's pregnant
yeah it's hard to tell what the hell she
said there
but shortly after that track hit the
airwaves nicki fuelled the rumors that
she was expecting when she did
a little q a over twitter telling one
fan that she's been craving
red meat and salad with extra jalapenos
and when another barb asked if she was
coping with morning sickness her
response no throwing up
but nausea and peeing non-stop omg
what do you think this means guys of
course that prompted people to ask for a
baby bump pick
and while nicki didn't post any pics at
the time
she did tease that fans would have to
wait a couple months for a reveal
adding the world ain't ready yet this
ultimate
couple's goals right here for real nikki
and kenneth tied the knot last october
and when it caught up with the grammy
nominee that same month
she said when it came to starting a
family they were
um practicing like how hard are we
practicing right now not to put you on
the spot
but the thing is okay
the truth is at first i was like i want
to know when and now i want it now
and then and then i started thinking
if i if i want it right right now or if
i want to wait like another year because
i have a couple things that i have to do
you